[Music]
nice to see you yeah I'll leave you
alone about Goodfellows and everything
okay yeah no I'm just gonna spend the
whole time staring at it
right um so a million things to talk
about but this is a first of all
Congrats on the movie you're what we
call a talented actor thank you right so
I always enjoy watching your work thank
you um what was it like I would imagine
you get offered a bunch of scripts what
was it about this one that said I want
to do this um I've never seen a film set
exactly in this I want to say period but
that's wrong because there's lots of
films set in the Second World War I
haven't seen another one you probably
have but I haven't seen another one set
exactly in the aftermath and what that
looked like that kind of
post-apocalyptic world and I think that
sense of rebuilding that sense of loss
you know in that very real sense that
okay there was a winning side and there
was a losing side but ultimately if
you've lost somebody that you loved
there is no winning and what does that
look like and how do you how do you get
past that and I think that in in the
sense so it's a very very grown-up love
story you know because what happens when
as a couple you've been through a great
tragedy and suddenly you are completely
different people
and you're looking at each other and it
should be the person that you know best
in the world and yet you don't recognize
them in any way how do you reach them
how do you come back together and in a
very literal sense how do you rebuild a
country after it's been completely
smashed to smithereens you know so I
thought all of these things were like
really interesting things to think about
and plus the idea of you know as an
English person and a German person
you've been taught to despise each other
you've been utterly dehumanized to each
other and you've been taught to kill
each other and to want to kill each
other for the last six years of war how
do you suddenly get over that you know
how do you suddenly have to see somebody
as a human being and and live under the
same roof as somebody and and forgive
how is that possible and of course the
in a way the great the extraordinary
thing about this generation is that they
did it Germany was rebuilt there has
been peace in Europe for the last 70
years you know the Japan was rebuilt
it's an extraordinary feat that these
nations managed to do it but actually
when you think about that process it's
kinda
unimaginable I actually don't even know
if it could be done in today's society
because we're so disconnected yes you
know not right now you know with our
modern leadership I am you have worked
with such talented directors and I'm
curious is directing something that
you're thinking about is it something
that you think you could do I don't know
at the moment with a three-year-old no
no no but but maybe further down the
line yeah I mean you know I've worked on
a lot of films I've worked with a lot of
wonderful directors yes and and I'm
really interested in how it's all put
together and and you know and and I
really like working with scripts and
storylines and and and all of that so I
think and I kind there's certain areas
that I'm confident that I'd be okay with
in certain areas where I'm not as
confident so we'll see in the future
have you been paying attention to like
lenses and stuff on set or you need to
be yes yeah yes I need to know you see
the problem is as an actor what I meant
to do is completely ignore that the
camera is there so it's taken me so long
to kind of completely ignore that the
cameras there that now if you're
thinking about directing then you need
to start going no really why are you
there and what lens you are completely
I'm already out of time with you I would
just say Congrats on the movie and I
wish you nothing but the best and you
thank you very much
you